[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know the thing about the clarinet is
that it can have worlds of expression
and it can do that in so many different
styles of music from classical music to
jazz to rock to all kinds of world music
and I felt that this project was a way
to remind everybody the possibilities of
it
[Music]
we are going to hear in one evening the
clarinet played by many different people
in many different ways we're hearing it
in a jazz setting we're hearing it in an
orchestral setting and I think that gave
a nice opportunity for the audience to
experience the full breadth of this
instrument
[Music]
I was glad to be invited and there's
some other good clarinet players playing
so I'm happy to be here
[Music]
clarinet is a phenomenally expressive
instrument even though it's tone tends
to be on the darker side
[Music]
any instrument that has survived for
centuries is there because people have
consistently found it to be a good
conduit for the channeling of human
thoughts and feelings and ideas and
emotions into sound my journey with the
clarinet this little fella has been with
me for over 30 years now
[Music]
[Music]
I started to play jazz going to high
school and I thought I'm gonna be able
to play clarinet but clarinet went out
of fashion apparently I did not know so
the teacher was it kind of discouraged
me from playing the clarinet he said why
don't you bring your brother saxophone
or any saxophone just don't bring the
clarinet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I was like a real little my dad was
like a jazz fan he'd always have me
listen to like these saxophone
recordings of David Sanborn
[Applause]
[Music]
third grade is where you earliest age
you could join the band program and so
every year they would show the beginning
third graders they'd have a presentation
where the fourth and fifth graders they
would go and play their instruments on
stage and the third graders in the
audience and then it was trying to
convince them to join the band and to
pick an instrument and so I kind of
wanted to play saxophone because a
little got my dad's influence I was his
favorite instrument but the clarinet was
like a lot smaller and like I realized
that it could fit in my backpack and I
would have to lug around like that that
of your saxophone
[Music]
[Music]
so backhand like the origin of July's
back in my Dixieland and like the New
Orleans type jazz like the claret I was
a very prominent instrument when like
jazz changed a lot from the swing era to
like the bebop era there were no famous
bebop it's a clarinetist you had Charlie
Parker on the saxophone and that's the
part of use where the saxophone has
become probably the dominating Sherman
in jazz clarinetist are mostly in the
big bands playing like this older swing
stuff and so the indirect quite make for
a shift like over to the new era
immediately there have been bebop is
clarinetist since then but there were no
like real figures for like people to
look up to I guess
[Music]
1 2 3 1 da da you need to articulate D
tardy it's all going somewhere go but oh
they did ah okay well it was another one
of Fred's ideas it's this whole thing
came to me in a dream and I can't
believe it actually happened it hasn't
happened yet but we've gotten this far
so this is very very cool
last year he mentioned something about a
clarinet summit where you get Evans and
Lauren and my instructor Billy Novick
and potentially some other people to
come play don byron right here Arana go
see Billy Novick Evan Zipporah
Fred's idea was to have a piece at the
end of the concert that would involve
all five players and that would be in
some way tailored to their strengths and
their inclinations their musical
inclinations and asked me if I could
write such a piece
[Music]
if we're celebrating the clarinet then
why don't we really go all the way and
celebrate it by inviting people who play
it I saw this concert advertised and
then I saw if you bring your own
instrument you can play along
and three
[Music]
[Applause]
the fact that we're inviting Clara nests
from around town to come and actually
play with us that's kind of
unprecedented if you just invite the
community at large then you're opening
yourself up to all levels of performance
ability and intonation and time 94 wins
who have these sixteenth note figures
there should not be articulate it's
really like that kind of thing
I mean you tongue it but the airstream
should not be broken really up until the
performance it kind of had that
edge-of-your-seat quality like is this
even gonna work is it gonna fall apart
I've been learning new notes throughout
the rehearsals
[Music]
[Music]
it's complicated you know it's it's
complicated music lot of shifting time
signatures and things and I'm not used
to that
[Music]
I really love the fact that this concert
is going to be not just about
celebrating the clarinet but celebrating
community
to be able to play with these great
clarinetists that's just you know
once-in-a-lifetime
[Music]
[Applause]
the rhythm to this piece changes so
often that it's really fun to play
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the whole thing about the clarinet is
that it's to me is a singularly kind of
18th 19th century contraption right like
if you look at it it's basically a
recorder with a bunch of like doohickeys
attached to it what I try to do is use
all these contraptions and use you know
the acoustic nature of the instrument
that is just this wooden tube that has a
lot of overtones or harmonics hidden in
it and just kind of bring those things
out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's idiomatic on the instrument are
things like you know Mozart right but
for me I'm much more interested in
finding ways to like get in the cracks
and so instead of playing like scales
I'd much prefer to do things like that's
based on an African yo TT or do things
you know that try to make the instrument
sound like a shakuhachi flute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a wonderful program and a great
opportunity and a wonderful gesture that
fred is bestowing upon us the
clarinetists to shine a spotlight on
this on this great instrument
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean clarinets such a nerdy instrument
let's face it Claire that's more
difficult to play than the saxophone so
it's harder to play like faster stuff
and complex changes and also the
clarinet isn't as loud as a saxophone or
the trumpet or other instruments
[Music]
since when it's like an adult instrument
it's very the tone quality and things
you can do in there may be much more
nuanced than sax
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but also has like a tremendous range
like it has a range of over three
octaves it sounds different in every
range so you can have a variety of
sounds that can come from it I did not
realize how versatile of an instrument
the clarinet wasn't when I first chose
it
you have what's known as the shallow
register the low register
[Music]
[Music]
very warm very rich and you have like
really high bright stuff like this is
called clarion register and clarion kind
of like a bell and then the altissimo
register which is the next register very
kind of more powerful kind of
penetrating piercing annoying people
might say sometimes that I like to use
some different registers to sort of
capture different voices almost
accompanying myself
[Music]
[Music]
I started playing an instrument because
I had asthma and my doctor said either
you know I could swim or I could play a
win instrument
everybody knows black people can't swim
so I ended up playing a Clannad down
[Music]
[Music]
I got a good sound on it it wasn't
intended to be a career move of any kind
but then it kind of ended up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when I play the clarinet I really feel
that I can be myself it's a great
instrument and it really can be part of
so many different sounds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ornament of the world is course based on
Middle Eastern and Islamic and Spanish
medieval themes so I had a sense that
she would have a connection to it that
nobody else would being from Israel
you can just really go straight to your
heart
[Music]
I'm working hard for people to realize
that it's not just belong to the music
of New Orleans or not just any good
[Music]
[Music]
planets like a knot and I have explored
a lot of ethnic things that are neither
jazz or classical because in those
musics there's more clowning there's
more client in Trinidadian music in
Colombian music in Brazilian music in
all of the Eastern European countries
there's even maybe more Asian clarinet
than there is jazz clarinet
[Music]
they're incredible fighters like if you
look up modern jazz clarinetist on
Google
Don Barden and not calling Papa the
chance to play along with people whose
music I've been listening to over a
decade seems unreal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]